Yes,
good day,
ladies and gentlemen.
I would also like to welcome them very warmly.
1 Danish proverb says,
the biggest step is through the door.
Why did I walk through the door with me?
My name is Ralf Sulkard I come from Karlsruhe.
After,
I was an independent It entrepreneur for 23 years.
Six years ago I sold the shares in my company and since then I have been
involved as an impact investor for n fair and sustainable economic system.
What was my motivation to be involved in the foundation here?
As one of the founders of Text Menau,
the topic of social justice is very close to my heart.
Unfortunately,
there has been and still is very little impulse from the traffic lights
at the moment for the people who are at the economic end of our society.
Moreover,
the economic policy of traffic lights is something that worries Me seriously.
Reason enough to seek contact with Sarah Wagenknecht.
I had offered Sarah,
in a conversation,
that I would contribute my experience as an
entrepreneur and also mentor from Start UPS to this project.
Today,
I am pleased that through the association that we have jointly founded,
reason can once again enter politics more,
and that this will benefit the many small and
medium-sized entrepreneurs in Germany in particular.
What is my role in the club?
As treasurer,
I have first responsibility for the financial affairs of the association.
It is particularly important to me that we
handle the funds entrusted to us carefully and,
above all,
efficiently.
Donations are now a central success factor for our political work,
especially in the initial phase.
I would like to put them on our website
alliance minus Sarah minus Wagenknecht point.
De point out that the only real website where
they find information about our association.
I look forward to everything that awaits us behind the door,
especially the appreciative cooperation with the
people who will enrich our alliance in the future.
Thank you for that too.
In view of the time and the Long List of Questions,
I would ask you to be as brief as possible so that we can give
as many colleagues as possible the opportunity to ask a question.
And I still hand over the word to hanleihe.
Yes, thank you very much.
Uh,
ladies and gentlemen.
Good morning also from me.
We are resigning from the left today and I can assure you,
none of us made this step easy.
We do this because we have no other choice politically.
Parties are not an end in themselves.
You must complete a task.
Our old party has not done this anymore
and all our attempts to correct the course,
when in vain our step here.
This is the consequence of it.
The frustration in the country is great.
People feel that they have the colliery numbers for war and for crisis.
They can literally watch their money being worth less every month,
times getting tougher for them.
They are afraid for their jobs in industry,
which are at risk from unthinkable economic and energy policies.
The schools her children go to are often in an
undignified state for 1 rich country like Germany.
The bridges are dilapidated,
bus and train arrive rarely and even more rarely on time.
The land was saved to pieces.
Meanwhile,
not only the facade isling.
Today,
the majority is looking to the future with concern.
You are afraid of low pensions,
you are concerned about the future of your children.
We want to build a new party that makes its back
straight for the working people in the country.
We want to build a party that straightens
its back for low- and middle-income people,
for pensioners,
for trade unionists and works councils.
The point is,
their concerns and questions take place far too frequently,
far too little in political debate.
More and more people feel that they are governed by in
parties that don't care about them and their concerns.
For years now,
parts of the population have not even gone to the polls.
The part of the population with little money
In my constituency in the north of Duisburg,
just 38 percent went to polls in the last state election.
We have 1 democracy problem and the Democrats have left that for far too long.
The current debates in the Bundestag
sometimes seem like they are from a different planet.
The traffic lights are arguing with the Union,
who is more to blame for the status quo?
The left side falls out and the right side sucks up
the anger in the population with their speech bubbles.
If there were federal elections today,
the left would almost certainly no longer be represented in the Bundestag,
and the right would enter there with over 20 percent.
We want to and we can't accept that.
We would like to face the political
responsibility of responding to this development.
We also set out to found a new party to lead an in democracy.
We know this challenge is big,
but we are organized,
we trust,
we know what we do and we bring experience.
We want to make Society 1 new political offer.
We need people who side with work in the population in the
crisis of capitalism trade unionists and experienced minds.
I also say clearly,
we will grow slowly and be controlled.
We will walk 1 step at a time.
Safety and are rapid successes.
We have come to stay.
Thank you very much and with the request to be as brief as possible,
I now turn the floor over to Mr.
Beautiful.
Yes,
thank you very much,
ladies and gentlemen.
Good morning.
Also from my side,
it is a great pleasure for me to speak
here this morning at theBundespressekonferenz.
My name is Luca beautiful.
And as Amira Mohammed Ali has just introduced,
I am the managing director of our association Bündnis,
Sarah warnknecht,
elected at the beginning of October for reason and justice.
I, too,
recently decided to leave the left and be part of building a new party.
This step was not easy for me either.
I was a founding member of the left in 2,007.
The left has long been my political home,
and has recently beenorganisationspolitischer
responsibility as managing director in North Rhine-Westphalia.
And the decision to leave all this behind me,
I have taken it out of political,
but as you can imagine,
also of course out of personal considerations.
Not made easy.
We do this today,
but together and out of innermost conviction.
We have decided to give a voice to the many people
in our country who have lost confidence in politics.
We want responsible policies that promote prosperity,
social balance and peace.
Sarah Wagenknecht just presented our political cornerstones.
So we will create a new party,
and that is also From my point of view drinks,
necessary and From an organizational point of view also a very exciting
task to found a new party is of course also 1 enormous feat of strength.
But I am sure that we will manage to do it together.
Our association is now making preparations for a party coronation in 01.2024.
We will establish 1 structures as a new party at the
beginning of the year and will be in the 1st quarter.
In the middle of the year we will 1 national constituency reasons,
and we will ensure a strong campaign performance for the year 2024,
because the new party will run in the European elections next year.
However,
our association is now in 1 line about preparing a party foundation.